ja vereinbarte Debatte das ist eine
Aussprache hier im Plenum des Deutschen
Bundestags bei der ist keine Vorlagen
gibt also keine Anträge keine
Gesetzentwürfe keine Regierungserklärung
sondern wo vor allem Themen besprochen
werden die weitreichend sind oder
umfangreich und das ganze dann auch eher
grundsätzlich und genauso ist es heute
morgen zum Thema nationale
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie die hat sich
die Bundesrepublik die Bundesregierung
seit 2002 gegeben regelmäßig angepasst
seit 2015 ungefähr basiert sie auf der
Agenda 2030 der Vereinten Nationen und
deren Nachhaltigkeitszielen von denen es
eine ganze Menge gibt über die wir dann
im Laufe des Vormittags auch eine ganze
Menge hören werden und es geht nicht nur
wie man meinen könnte um Natur Umwelt
oder Klimaschutz sondern es geht auch um
globale Verantwortung dabei um sozialen
Zusammenhalt oder auch um Bildung
Wissenschaft und Innovation also ein in
der Tat sehr weitreichendes Feld und
deswegen wollen wir das ein bisschen
aufdröseln ein bisschen Hintergrund auch
liefern worum es dann in den nächsten
drei Stunden hier im Parlament gehen
wird und ich freue mich dass bei auf den
Tessa gansera die Obfrau ist im
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung auch ein Gremium das uns
nicht ganz so präsent ist und Wolfgang
stiefinger ist bei uns der ist der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende eben dieses
Gremiums Frau gansera sie sind
Diplom-Ingenieure für Wald und
Forstwirtschaft wir wissen dass
Nachhaltigkeit aus dem Forstwirtschaft
kommt aus diesem Sektor und trotzdem
wird es übertragen auch auf andere
Bereiche das ist beim Thema Wirtschaft
noch einigermaßen nachvollziehbar Wurf
ist Nachhaltigkeit aber beispielsweise
bei Bildung oder bei Wissenschaft nun
mit der nachhaltigen Entwicklung er
verfolgen wir kein geringeres Ziel als
dass alle Menschen auf dieser Erde ein
gutes Leben im Würde ermöglicht wird und
das auch unseren künftigen Generationen
unseren Enkeln und urenkelkindern und
dazu müssen wir unsere ganze Lebens- und
Wirtschaftsweise so gestalten dass wir
die globalen Grenzen die ökologischen
Grenzen auch halten und soll großes Ziel
erreicht man natürlich nicht mit einem
Debatte mit einem Beschluss dafür
braucht es langfristige Strategie der
Punkt der ich meinte war wenn man auf
die auf die Wälder guckt auf die Nutzung
von Wäldern wo der Begriff wie gesagt
herkommt irgendwie das nur so viel Bäume
geschlagen werden wie man auch wieder
neu anpflanzen kann also dass er ein
gewisses Gleichgewicht bleibt wie muss
ich mir dieses übertragen vorstellen auf
die Bereiche Bildung oder Wissenschaft
das war der Punkt gerade bildung ist der
Schlüssel auch zur gesellschaftlichen
Teilhabe zum guten Leben und deswegen
sind natürlich bei diesem Ziel in der
nachhaltigen Entwicklung dass alle
Menschen nur gutes Leben führen können
auch solche Themen wie
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit und Bildung
hier in Deutschland aber auch globaler
ganz wichtiges Anliegen den
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung gibt es seit 2004
schildern Sie uns ein bisschen der
stehfinger was das Gremium macht das hat
ja haben wir gelesen in der Vorbereitung
eine sogenannte wach-funktion erläutern
Sie das mal ein bisschen
ja vielen Dank für die Frage ist es so
dass dieser parlamentarische Beirat eben
gegründet wurde um auch eine
Aufsichtsfunktion des Parlamentes
gegenüber der Bundesregierung zu haben
das Parlament korrigiert ja und auch
kontrolliert auch die Regierung und
deswegen sind alle Gesetze auch hier in
dem parlamentarischen Beirat
mitzuüberprüfen ob die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele eben eingesetzt und
eingehalten werden von der
Bundesregierung und dafür gibt es diesen
parlamentarischen Beirat für nachhaltige
Entwicklung wir von der Union hätten ihn
gerne als ordentlichen Ausschuss gehabt
das hat die neue Mehrheit im Parlament
nicht mitgemacht aber ich denke auch so
wird dieser Beirat seiner Funktion
gerecht um einfach die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele wirklich in den
Gesetzgebungen auch zu überprüfen sagen
Sie mal konkret wo sie dann tatsächlich
tätig geworden sind bislang in dieser
Wahlperiode das sind natürlich Themen
jetzt bei der Energieversorgung
beispielsweise das sind Themen Mobilität
also die unterschiedlichsten Bereiche
wenn sie sich die 17
Nachhaltigkeitsziele anschauen
wir haben selber schon angesprochen
Bildung Forschung ob das Entwicklung ist
ob das Wasserversorgung ist
Umweltschutz wirtschaftliche Themen also
wirklich es gibt im Endeffekt kaum ein
Gesetzesvorhaben dass der
parlamentarische Beirat nicht auch mit
begleiten muss weil es eben immer um
dieses große Thema Nachhaltigkeit geht
Nachhaltigkeitsziele hat sie
Bundesregierung seit 2002 gesetzt warum
sind wir nicht weiter heute im Jahr 2022
nun ich denke es ist erst einmal wichtig
positiv herauszuheben dass wir seit 2002
diese Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie haben und
dass alle Bundesregierungen über die
verschiedensten parteipolitischen
Farbspiele hinweg an diese
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie festgehalten
haben und die auch weiterentwickelt
solche großen Ziele erreichen auch nicht
von heute auf morgen deswegen muss er
immer wieder überprüft werden wo sind
wir und dann falls sie eben auch nach
Steuern und gerade jetzt auch die
letzten Jahre die corona-pandemie jetzt
dieser bürgerliche Angriffskrieg stellte
Politik immer wieder vor neuen
Herausforderungen auf die kurzfristig
Antworten gefunden werden müssen und
deswegen braucht es auch immer wieder
Überprüfung ich glaube langfristig
müssen wir dahin gehen dass wir diese
nachhaltigkeitsüberprüfung der Gesetze
noch mal sehr verstellen also hört sich
ein bisschen so an als wenn Sie
zufrieden mit dem Stand der Dinge kann
mir nicht also zufällig mir nicht
vorstellen kann man nicht sein wenn wir
uns den Indikatoren anschauen in
Deutschland aber auch global dann sind
wir noch meilenweit davon entfernt diese
Nachhaltigkeitsziele einzuhalten zu
erreichen und deswegen brauchen wir da
auch noch mal kräftigere Anstrengungen
ich halte wichtig dass wir wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart bei der
gesetzesfolgen Abschätzung noch mal ganz
genau um viel genauer hinschauen
vielleicht dann nochmal Zielkonflikte
deutlich aufmachen und frühzeitig zu
erkennen wenn es in die falsche angeht
oder wenn man nicht schnell genug
vorwärts kommen warum Herr stefinger
sind wir nicht weiter dieselbe Frage
auch an sie ich würde das gar nicht so
Probleme sind ja bekannt also ich würde
es gar nicht so negativ sehen weil wenn
wir uns insgesamt die Situation
anschauen wir waren schon auf einem sehr
guten Weg wenn ich jetzt auch als
entwicklungspolitiker sagen darf auch
das Ziel eine Welt ohne Hunger das war
ein ambitioniertes Ziel bis 2030 ob wir
es geschafft hätten ich glaube wir
hätten es vielleicht knapp hinbekommen
wäre Corona nicht gekommen also solche
Punkte glaube ich muss man schon auch
sehen wenn wir auch anschauen weltweit
global wie sich auch die Sterblichkeit
bei Frauen verringert hat Geburten nach
Geburten beispielsweise all diese Themen
sind auch alle mit in der
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie drin da waren
wir und sind wir auch auf einem sehr
sehr guten Weg wir haben natürlich es
auch immer wieder mit Rückschlägen zu
tun das darf man auch nicht
wegdiskutieren aber wir waren und sind
auf einem guten Weg und man darf diese
Anstrengungen halt nicht nachlassen das
ist jetzt das große Thema auch gerade
auch im Entwicklungsbereich ich kann nur
immer wieder auch sagen
Entwicklungspolitik ist globale
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik und wir müssen
alle Themen auch global denken wir
dürfen nicht die Sicht auch beim Klima
nicht die Sicht alleine auf Deutschland
verengen oder auf Europa wir müssen auch
die wachsenden Regionen dieser Erde
anschauen und da kommen wir an Afrika
nicht vorbei alleine wenn wir das
Bevölkerungswachstum anscheinend alleine
wenn wir überlegen dass auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent 600 Millionen
Menschen keinen Zugang zu einer
Steckdose haben diesen aber auch haben
wollen also sehen wir alleine schon wie
auch hier der Bedarf zu decken ist und
deswegen ist Entwicklungspolitik
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik wenn ich selber
richtig verstehe würden Sie dann die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele die die Ampel im
Koalitionsvertrag zumindest genannt und
aufgelistet hat im Prinzip dann auch
zustimmen es sind viele wichtige Punkte
dabei auf die wir uns ja auch schon
lange gemeinsam international
verständigt haben die im
Koalitionsvertrag ist ja nichts neues
drin das sind die die sdgs also die die
nachhaltigkeits die noch mal
ausformuliert wurden und das Wichtige
ist aber nochmal dass wir die Sicht
nicht verengen und deswegen verstehe ich
beispielsweise nicht warum die Ampel
massiv im entwicklungsetat kürzt weil
das ist eigentlich der zukunftsetat
gerade was die Nachhaltigkeit betrifft
direkt mal nach
vor
also ich
will das jetzt nicht beschönigen wir
brauchen natürlich auch international
mehr Anstrengungen und zwar in allen
Bereichen nicht nur in einzelnen wir
brauchen denke ich global mehr
Anstrengungen beim internationalen
Klimaschutz weil das ist eine eine Krise
die die uns immer stärker auf betrifft
und hier hat Deutschland ganz große
Verantwortung und da haben wir in
Koalitionsvertrag auch in den letzten
Monaten da ganze Reihe am Paketen auf
dem Weg gebracht um diese Ziele auch zu
erreichen ich will trotzdem noch mal auf
die Relevanz unter die Bedeutung dieses
parlamentarischen Beirats zurück sie
haben schon angedeutet dass sie sich da
mehr wünschen trotzdem gibt es keine
beziehungsweise wie sehen dann die
Empfehlungen ganz konkret aus im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren auf der einen
Seite den der Bericht zu den
Nachhaltigkeitszielen der kommt ja von
der Bundesregierung und nicht aus diesem
nicht aus diesem Beirat wieso eigentlich
nicht
also der parlamentarische Beirat haben
in den letzten Jahren sehr viele gute
Denkanstöße gebracht auch das Thema
sustandable also nachhaltige Finanzen
war so ein Thema das dabei Rad auf dem
Weg gebracht hat wir begleiten auch den
staatssekretärsausschuss für nachhaltige
Entwicklung wo wir im Vorbereitung auf
diese Sitzungen auf unsere eigenen
Positionspapiere erarbeiten können
einspeisen können und damit auch
Einfluss auf die
Nachhaltigkeitspolitik der
Bundesregierung nehmen können also ich
würde einfach ergänzen ja dass wir
wirklich auktionsfeier angesprochen
diese wach und Funktion haben und eben
dann auch wenn wir sehen das läuft in
die falsche Richtung dann auch wirklich
laut bellen so wie das ein Wachhund am
Ende des Tages auch machen sollte aber
man kriegt es in der Öffentlichkeit
nicht wirklich richtig mit ne
heute ist ein guter Anfang dass wir bei
Ihnen sein dürfen vielleicht machen wir
das öfter und können dann auch über
dieses Thema diskutieren wofür es am
meisten Frauen über was sie
Nachhaltigkeit angeht in welchem
sektorverkehr Landwirtschaft Bildung
also Herr stefinger hat ja schon
Entwicklungspolitik angesprochen dürfen
den einen Bereich nicht gegen den
anderen Ausspielen des soziale
Gerechtigkeit der Zugang zu Bildung ist
genauso wichtiges Anliegen für gutes
Leben für alle Menschen wie der
Klimaschutz und deswegen müssen wir
überall dort wo wir noch Defizite haben
unsere Kraftanstrengungen nochmal
erhöhen die haben schon den Einfluss der
Pandemie eben angesprochen welche frage
ich noch mal andersrum ich will die gar
nicht will die gar nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen aber welcher Weg ist im
Moment der Stein nicht so formuliere ich
mal so oder welcher Bereich ist der
schwierigste ich glaube das gerade keine
einfache also gerade jetzt diese
fürchterliche Angriffskrieg der von
Putin auch mit Getreide mit
Nahrungsmitteln und mit hungern geführt
hat für uns natürlich bei mein Ziel den
Hunger in dieser Welt zu reduzieren
nochmal vor viel größeren
Herausforderungen wir haben einmal das
Thema Klimaschutz dass man genauso wenig
aus den Augen verlieren dürfen wie den
Erhalt der natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen
weil eben auch der Verlust der
Artenvielfalt
massive Auswirkungen auf stabile
Ökosysteme die die Grundlage für unser
ganzes Leben sind haben und deswegen
müssen wir in allen Bereichen tätig
werden Nachhaltigkeit das ist genau der
Punkt den ich den hier auf den ich jetzt
auch noch mal kommen wollte ist im
Grunde ja eine Querschnittsaufgabe es
geht ist ressortübergreifend wird wir
haben es eben auch schon gehört im
Kanzleramt im Großen und Ganzen
koordiniert ist das dadurch dass es so
eine Querschnittsaufgabe ist auch schon
mein Problem an sich um um auch einen
einzelnen Punkte besser ranzukommen das
sehe ich nicht es ist einfach so wie bei
Digitalisierung auch das ist einfach ein
Thema das alle aber das hängt sehr auch
alle Bereiche betrifft und von daher das
Wichtige ist glaube ich wirklich wenn
wir uns auf diese sdg-ziele
lebendigen auf die Nachhaltigkeitsziele
das dann auch jedes Ministerium jede
Behörde eben auch in dem eigenen Beritt
in dem eigenen Bereich eben auch schauen
muss dass diese Ziele auch eingehalten
sind darum geht es auch es geht auch
darum ein gewisses Bewusstsein zu
schaffen am Ende ist die Politik kann
auch oft nur Rahmenbedingungen geben am
Ende hängt auch an uns an allen an den
Verbrauchern an einem Konsumenten und da
kann auch die Behörden die Exekutive mit
dazu dass man auch hier drüber nachdenkt
und sich auch frägt wie nachhaltig sind
wir auch in unserem eigenen Handeln wie
klimaneutrales der Bundestag sind die
Behörden beispielsweise die die
Landesministerien all diese Themen
spielen dann natürlich mit entscheidende
Rolle und ich glaube es geht auch um
bewusstseins-
jetzt gleich in zwei drei Minuten also
ich hoffe und wir wünschen dass wir uns
nicht im parteipolitischen kleinen
zehrten sondern wirklich die
Gemeinsamkeiten herausarbeiten und das
heißt an dieser Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
festhalten die weiter fortschreiben das
Thema
viel mehr Bedeutung im Deutschen
Bundestag zu verleihen und auch zu
erkennen dass wir Ressort übergreifend
arbeiten müssen und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen mehr Ehrlichkeit in der Debatte
das Leben ist nicht schwarz-weiß macht
man gibt es heute Zielkonflikte und die
glaube ich muss mal offen machen dass
man dann auch erkennt wenn man sich für
einen eine Richtung entscheidet um
bestimmte Ziele der nachhaltigen
Entwicklung zu erreichen das ist
Konflikte in anderen Bereichen gibt aber
wenn man das offen transparent macht
dann wird er aber auch deutlich dass man
diesen Bereichen in Zukunft noch mehr
Kraftanstrengung braucht und das würde
ich mir wünschen mehr Ehrlichkeit und
wirklich die Themen vernetzt denken
hätte ich eine Chance in einer
vereinbarten Debatte heute irgendwie wo
man sich nicht um einzelne Anträge
streiten muss und sind ihre Erwartungen
also meine Erwartung ist dass wir
wirklich das Thema offen miteinander
diskutieren ich darf aber schon auch
eins sagen dass ich sehr bedauerlich
finde dass die jetzige Regierung die
debattenzeit auf drei Stunden reduz hat
die Union hat in der letzten Wahlperiode
eine ganze Woche Nachhaltigkeit gemacht
und das finde ich schon sehr sehr schade
dass gerade eine Regierung und der
Beteiligung der Grünen nur noch drei
Stunden Zeit findet um über dieses
wichtige Thema zu diskutieren und auch
das könnte ein Thema werden in der
Debatte Frau gansera vielen Dank dass
Sie heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind
auch Ihnen Herr stefinger herzlichen
Dank sie dürfen jetzt auch reingehen
wird doch jetzt noch ein bisschen knapp
oder ein bisschen knapper als ich
gehofft hatte aber das macht nichts wir
haben wichtige Punkte besprochen im
Vorfeld dieser Debatte die jetzt hier
gleich beginnt vielen dank ihnen